m
ça change quand même beaucoup de choses
sont obligés d'aller fumer le cigare
ailleurs dans au fond à gauche la droite
molle tout coller ses douces et plus
dans la même pièce enfin vous avez
changé quelque chose alors à votre façon
de vivre
ah bah non c'est à dire que c'est lui
qui entrera dans la doute surtout on va
pas tous transformés pour lui au
contraire c'est à lui à s'habituer à
notre lit je pense enfin il ya quand
même des alarmes de retour et
effectivement certaines vedettes font
participer des enfants leur vie publique
qu'est ce que vous allez faire je suis
partisane du contraire parce que je
trouve que j'ai offensés nuclé la vie la
plus normale possible jamais parlé il ya
quelques années jacques dutronc vous
avez sorti vous avez inventé un piège à
filles mais est-ce que nous allons
transmettre ce secret votre fille ont
grandi est ce que vous avez bien sûr
j'espère je voulais le prendre je
voulais je voulais vendre et en fait
j'ai gardé je pense qu'ils s'en servira
c'est pas du tout usage propre il est
pas rouillé du tout et ça marchera sur
20 et puis peut-être que je serais pas
si vieux que ça à l'époque où il en
servira on pourra toujours se cacher